from what I remember I listened to your
episode with with uh Rogan your dad was
kind of like a like a pretty tough guy
right one of those like vintage New York
tough guys yes back in the day now he's
got you know now he's on dialysis with
two fake knees
um but but but he's back in the day
you know I think a lot of guys in you
know he's from the Bronx I think a lot
of guys in the 70s 80s even early 90s
got mixed up with those guys you know
gambling right and and running around
and it's just an easy way to make money
like hey you know you you work for this
family you know go pick up this gambling
death that gambling debt so you get to
know those guys not that he was ever a
maid guy or whatever right but you get
to know those guys you get to know those
Circle you know those people was that
collected money yeah yeah pretty much
like uh his job I would call like it was
it was like a different work number
every week and somebody would just be
like accounting and it was always like
some guy some different guy you know I I
had no idea like so we'd have to go
shake down the business owners yeah I I
guess yeah because that's the thing with
my dad is I never really asked too many
questions on what he did but I just like
would always get I would always get like
because my parents got divorced right
when I was very young yeah and I would
always get like kind of hints of like oh
my mom doesn't like believe my dad or
like my dad because like I remember one
time like being a little kid and being
like Dad like you know like it's career
day tomorrow like what do you do for
like work what's your job again like my
mom being like my mom she was like
making dinner she's like I'd love to see
what he says now you know like she's
like let's see what Tony what [ __ ]
accounting well no I remember he said he
goes I go I go he works and he said he
goes he goes oh oh Chris I work for the
banks and I was like oh you oh you
worked for the bank somebody was like
the banks that just kept like you know
making the spaghetti and I was like and
I was like yeah she was just you know I
don't remember like not like just be
like okay is that why your mom divorced
him well dude no my mom said they my mom
served divorce papers to my dad when she
was pregnant with me because he gambled
this was 1984 I was I was born in 84.
okay so the Jordan year he was drafted
in 84. no 1984 there's a book I forgot
what I think it's called Glory years
it's about how Wild the year 1984 was I
haven't read it yet but there's like a
lot of [ __ ] that went down in 1994.
um but so 84 uh uh my dad
um you know bad Gambler whatever took
like eight thousand dollars of like my
of their like ten thousand dollar
savings and betted on like the Montreal
Expos like some [ __ ] random thing
and they lost and then so and then I
think what happened was is my somebody
called my dad didn't pay up and somebody
called my mom at like whatever it is 10
p.m it was like where's the money I know
you're pregnant you don't want to fall
down to fly to stairs like [ __ ] like
that and then my mom took me to like
Lancaster Pennsylvania like we got it we
gotta get out of Dodge got out of Dodge
came back gave birth but then I think
that was like the beginning of the end
and then uh but but but my dad always
says he's like you know when you were
born like that was like that's when I
feel like I hit the lotto like that like
you and then he started to like slowly
get out of it all and now I mean I don't
know anything like about I have multiple
family members uh on my dad's side who
were like murdered and stuff like that's
like real on the nose mom and she
murdered like shot like shot and killed
police never investigated it so it's
like you know like sleep with the fishes
oh yeah so I'm like so that stuff I'm
like oh see that's the thing with like
with like organized crime and all that
like it's it's cool and romanticized in
the movies and it is it is I get why but
when it's actually in your family you're
like
who is like the closest relative to you
that you that passed my uh Uncle so my
my aunts husband but I was again a
little kid but him and his son my cousin
would just murdered like shot to death
at work in Long Island uh uh New Jersey
yeah I do yeah then when you look it up
it's like that there was no leads no
nothing and then it's crazy my aunt got
um and this is like a a mafia thing my
aunt got I don't know for the amount of
time but like every month behind like
one of the plants give me money bag of
money because probably the family that
killed him are like well we got to take
care of the wife if we're gonna yeah
take him out see those guys see see
that's the thing like the Mafia the
Italian mafia I understand the extortion
and and the crimes I get it I get why
it's bad I really do but there is a
little bit there's a little code there's
a little bit of like well it's a little
bit safer when the mafia's around
they're not gonna here's the thing it's
yes it sucks I gotta pay this fee this
extortion fee that sucks but you know
what no one's ever gonna break into my
business no one's ever gonna hurt my
kids because if they do their [ __ ]
dead and they will not mess with you
unless you mess with them at least the
old guys were the noob people you know I
don't know but the old guys my father
always say the only people you got to
watch out for in this world are Mafia
wannabes the wannabes are the guys who
will hurt you because they don't live by
the code the guys who buy the code you
never see it coming you just get one at
the back of the head but they would
never touch you unless you did something
to them and they would you know I
remember being in um uh Cross Bay
Boulevard the Howard Beach always would
have a festival right like a carnival
every year and I remember going there
once with my dad and John Gotti and his
guys were handing out free candy to all
the kids I was like this guy's [ __ ]
like Jesus did you get any candy from it
of course wow yeah no we were with all
the kids it gave it to all the kids he
was just John Gotti you got some John
Gotti's candy somebody Mafia candy yeah
it was like a big deal like a kid's what
there's a million kids did he say hi to
your dad no he's like hey it's been a
while good to see you no but you know
what's funny it's he didn't say hi to my
dad but when John Gotti died his funeral
was in Queens and I remember my dad was
like you know uh I lived in Queens right
and my dad you know I was a teenager by
then so it's not like I knew his you
know whereabouts every second of the day
but but he called me he's like I'm in
Queens you want to get a slice of pizza
I'll meet you by your mother's house and
I was like oh cool and then I I said I
was like why are you in Queen's a guy my
friend died I went to their funeral and
I was like oh
because I know that but but I never
asked like but it kind of not it could
not it could have been coincidence
exactly if I'm you I'm like Dad yeah
you're on dialysis yeah you got two old
knees or new knees whatever yeah let's
peel back the onion give me some of
these stories I know I know let's do a
podcast yeah yeah no he wouldn't that's
the thing because he wouldn't say
because he's very much like I don't want
you near this right you know but it was
funny when I remember that day was like
I was at a friend's funeral I was like
oh John Gotti yeah yeah okay oh man
imagine it wasn't it was just like a
neighbor yeah
you just came up with this coincidence
in your head none of it's real he's
never in the mafia it's okay no no he
actually worked for the banks yeah no he
genuinely works for Chase yeah my mother
he cheated on my mom yeah that's why she
just [ __ ] she just she's just bitter
yeah that's all it is